I'm Brendan Lake from NYU and my talk is
called concepts and questions as
programs so as Andy mentioned I'm
cognitive scientist and I study
computational problems that are easier
for people than they are for machines so
there's been a lot of exciting recent
progress in AI and machine learning yet
for most types of everyday cognitive
abilities people are still better
learners and thinkers than machines are
and by everyday cognitive ability I mean
things like concept learning asking a
question understanding a scene or tasks
that involve creativity general-purpose
problem solving reasoning language
understanding speech recognition and so
on and my research has two main goals to
better understand people and also to try
to build a more human-like learning
capacity in machines and today I'm gonna
focus on two of the abilities on this
slide I'm gonna focus on concept
learning and asking questions for
concept learning for me the motivating
question is how do people learn such
rich concepts from very little data
imagine this is your first time seeing a
Segway you just see that image of a
Segway at the top of the screen that
single image might be enough information
for you to basically get what the
concept of a Segway is and you can
recognize it again even if its features
or its appearance have changed and be
able to rule out other distractors that
share some properties in common with the
original image so this ability is often
called one-shot learning it's been of
interest to cognitive scientists and and
AI researchers for a long time in
addition to learning very quickly people
also seem to learn very rich
representation so by the time that you
can recognize a Segway you can do many
other things with that concept with that
mental representation you can use it the
parse an object into its most important
parts and relations you could use it to
generate new examples you could sketch
your own version of a Segway or you
could even generate a new concept so if
you take a Segway and a motorcycle and a
unicycle and combine them together you
could think up or imagine new
vehicles like like the one on this life
so how do people do this how do they
learn rich concepts from small amounts
of experience and it's interesting to
contrast this with some of the the
biggest breakthroughs in machine
learning and AI particularly in in the
space of object recognition where we
have these deep neural networks that are
trained on very large amounts of data so
this is the famous alex net deep
convolutional neural network and it's
trained on the image net task which has
1.2 million images and about a thousand
images per class and the models very
large it has 60 million free parameters
and below I'm listing some of the the
more recent versions that won the
imagenet challenge in the years after
alex net and these these models are
trained on very large datasets rather
than on small data sets and also their
primary focus is on classification as
opposed to some of the other abilities I
just had on the slide show pathological
cases yeah in one one of the case
studies I'll go through I'll show some
stimuli that they don't seem to match
people's judgments in this the second
part which is going to be shorter is
gonna be about asking questions I'm
gonna give you a little teaser about
what I mean by this so when people are
asking questions um while learning this
is a form of active learning and if you
imagine you're a child and you're
learning about different types of
instruments and you have these objects
in front of you you might ask questions
like you know and you don't fully
understand how instruments work yet you
might ask how does a saxophone make a
sound or what's the difference between
the second object and the third object
what's the difference between a trumpet
and a horn or what features are
especially important about a French horn
and in contrast there are active
learning systems in machine learning so
are you ready for what the standard
robot questions look like was it made up
nope so
so most of the time in active learning
the question has this form what is the
category label of this object and what
is the category label of this subject
and what is the category label of this
object and I'm being a bit unfair
there's has been interesting work in
active learning and robotics about
asking richer types of questions but I
think it's fair to say that we have no
algorithm that matches the
sophistication and the richness of the
human ability to ask questions when
learning new things
so here's the outline of what I'm going
to talk about today in concept learning
I'm going to go through two different
case studies one on handwritten
characters and the other on recursive
visual concepts and then I'm going to
talk about a third domain which is
active learning with richer types of
questions
the title of the talk is concepts and
questions as programs and by programs I
mean expressions in some structured
description languages that's a lot like
a programming language and we're going
to think about what the structure can
you represent each of these domains with
with a former program and what what is
the structure of those programs what
what are their semantics and and that's
gonna be one of the unifying themes
across these different domains but I
want to add a disclaimer that by the end
of the talk there isn't going to be a
single piece of software that you could
run out of the box on many different
types of datasets so the main goal is to
try to study the the principles and the
representations that people might use to
to solve some of these problems and use
that to inspire more human-like learning
algorithms but it's still going to take
work to try to use these ideas and these
algorithms in in different types of
domains so it does it's not an
out-of-the-box approach yet and there's
there's an alternative title for this
talk instead of about concepts and
questions as programs I could have
called it or named it after these three
key principles that are going to thread
through the the different case studies
that I talked about and these principles
are compositionality causality and
learning to learn and I'm gonna tell you
a bit more about what I mean by these
different things and I think learning
programs is a very natural way to
implement
different principals together and a
single type of computational approach
but the principles are more general than
this particular approach and you can
imagine integrated them into other types
of machine learning and AI paradigms so
this is the other way you can think
about some some of the ideas here okay
so let's get into the first case study
which is about Henry and characters so
this work is joint with Josh Tenenbaum
and Russell kunafa josh is at MIT and
Russ is at Carnegie Mellon and it
recently appeared in the journal Science
so reminding you about this question how
is it that people learn rich concepts
from very little data we wanted to study
this ability and we wanted a testbed
domain that had certain characteristics
where we wanted the concepts to be
natural and high dimensional and have
enough structure of real world objects
but we also wanted them to be simple
enough that we had a reasonable chance
of building a computational model that
could see most of the structure and in
the stimuli that people can sew and we
could compare people and and machines on
a roughly even footing and we also
wanted a domain that could help us
generate insights that that were more
general than that particular to me so
the domain we picked is handwritten
characters and if you're a machine
learning person you almost certainly
know about the endless data set which is
a standard benchmark and in terms of
concept learning there's ten concepts
which are the the ten different digits 0
through 9 and there's 6000 training
examples of each of the digits in this
data set and we have a new data set
which we call the Omniglot data set
which you can download at github on
github if you want to try it out and we
think of this as as the transpose of
endless store the more human-like
version of endless because rather than
just have a few concepts and a lot of
data points for each one we have many
different concepts 1600 different
concepts and 20 examples of each of them
and the concepts are picked from 50
different laying alphabets some of them
real some of them synthetic and there's
just a small number of data points for
each one
so I showed you these interesting things
you can do with a concept like a Segway
and it turns out you can do a lot of
these interesting rich abilities with
simpler concepts like a handwritten
character so first of all let's see if
you can learn a new character from a
single data point so everyone take a
look at the the image at the top of the
screen there and in the grid below is an
is another example of that character
written by somebody else so I'm gonna
move my laser pointer across the screen
and I'm gonna ask if you could clap your
hands if I touch another example of that
character is everyone ready all right
yep so that was some excellent one-shot
learning you clearly didn't need
thousands of images just a single one is
enough and I'm in addition to doing
classification from a small amount of
data you could also parse it you know
about efficient ways you could produce
it you could generate your own examples
of that letter you can even generate new
letters in the style of other letters so
your concept of a letter is a lot richer
than just the ability to do recognition
and we want to study on that
representation and try to figure out
what it can be so an interesting part of
the omnigul data set in addition to
having the images we have a little movie
showing how it was produced so it was
drawn on Mechanical Turk by a bunch of
different volunteers and the different
colors here are different pen strokes
that they use but they're using their
computer mice and you can see there's a
lot of consistency in how people draw
this novel character in terms of where
they start their their movements how
many parts what are the parts and so
here's 20 people drawing this letter for
the first time then they draw it like
this I'll show you another example for
me this letter clearly has four parts
and almost everybody agreed and there's
also a lot of consistency and in the way
that people decided to draw it in terms
of where they started the movements and
what direction they move
question for this particular one does it
matter whether you had Western European
or Middle Eastern people doing it let me
write verses right to left yeah we have
a bunch of data for that where we know
the country for each person we didn't do
very much with it and I think we should
but at least the the starting at the top
of the character and moving left to
right is as seems to be a very universal
thing even even if the language is
actually written right to left unless
unless you're left handed and then and
then you do it the other way but that
that Elise seems to be pretty strong
across other languages I'll show you one
more movie of 20 people drawing this
letter so when we saw this data it
seemed like people weren't just doing
something arbitrary they they somehow
inferred a structured representation
where they're able to efficiently
produce it and it was something like a
motor program perhaps so we took this
idea quite literally and um developed a
model that we call Bayesian program
learning and the main idea here is
concept learning as a type of program
induction and there's some key
ingredients for learning good programs
and I'll tell you a little bit about
what these ingredients are I've
mentioned them earlier compositionality
causality and learning to learn the
first ingredient this compositionality
and this is this old idea that
representations can be constructed from
a combination of parts and primitives so
if you know about vehicles and you know
about wheels and handlebars and posts
and seats and motors and how these
different parts relate to one another
when you see a Segway for the first time
if you parse it into these parts and
relations it gives you a rich
representation that can help you pick
out new examples of the same concept so
that's that's the compositionality idea
this the second ingredient is about
causality and it's this idea that
generative models at an abstract level
can capture real causal structure where
the data comes from in the world and
this is an observation about digits from
hinted in there where they pointed out
that these twos they differ a lot in
pixel space they may not share many
pixels in common
but they're very similar in motor space
basically the same move
produces all those different twos on on
the screen and that could be a better
representation for generalization you
can also think about a concept like a
tree where you could find features to
help you recognize it and identify trees
but there's also some deeper causal
structure there about how trees grow in
terms of branches growing and then the
branches themselves branching and we
have a lot of additional knowledge
beyond just features that we use to
recognize it and the third ingredient is
what we call learning to learn which is
this idea that you become better at
learning concepts as you learn more of
them so in terms of handwritten
characters the the model learns a lot
about the structure of of letters in
general so it's trained on about half of
Omniglot where it gets a lot of
experience with letters and knows about
how many strokes tend to be in letters
and where's the strokes tend to start
like the first strokes tenth tends to
start in the top left and the second
stroke tends to be a little bit more
diffuse and so on it learns about motor
primitives in terms of some basic
movements that people tend to use when
they're producing letters it learns
about how much your affine
transformation there is from one person
running it to the next it learns about
different relations and and what when
strokes tend to attach to one another
and and what the different sort of types
of relations are so those are what we
mean by learning to learn with this type
of knowledge it can help you become a
better learner so the model is
pre-training Don on letters from other
alphabets and then tested on new ones so
the idea of this Bayesian programming
learning model or the BPL model and also
the codes on github if you want to try
it is that we have a generative model or
a program for generating new letters and
you can run it and sample new new types
of letters where the first step is the
sample how many parts you want which are
the strokes then for each stroke you
sample how many sub parts you want which
are the primitive motor actions that
make up a stroke you didn't sample
relations how the different parts that
attach to one another and then you
return an object which itself is a piece
of code another program so that's that's
a program that generates type
of letters and it returns a subprogram
that generates different instances of
that letter so now every time you run
this program it adds some motor noise
some differences in terms of exactly how
the strokes are laid out it has
transformations and then it renders it
down into a binary image that the motor
trajectory and you can produce different
variations of of the same letter so
that's the structure of the model it's a
it's a full probabilistic generator of
model that's amber samples types and
then the site the types can sample
tokens and we can use Bayes rule to
reason about what's the probability of
the the program's theta given an image I
so all the model C's is a new letter
just just the binary image and it has to
reason about what's an efficient motor
program to have generated this image
that I that I saw how how is it likely
to be generated and we can treat this as
a problem of Bayesian inference so I'm
going to show you a few of the things
that the model can do and in the paper
we go through all the tasks on the
screen but I'm just going to show you a
little bit from a few a few of the tests
the first task is the generated new
example tasks so here people were shown
a new character like the image at the
very top left of the screen and we asked
nine different people on Mechanical Turk
to produce a new example of that letter
and then we not ask the model to do the
same task we showed it exactly the same
binary image and then we asked it to
produce nine new examples of that letter
so you can treat this as a visual Turing
test can you guess which of these grids
is the model and which of these grids is
the people so I'm gonna pull the
audience I'm gonna ask you which is the
machine a or B so we're gonna look at
the top left one over there so one of
those grids of nine is people and one of
them is the machine so so which one do
you think is the machine hey B okay well
just for show of hands any votes for a
okay thank you for you for a B all right
very good let's try the one in the
bottom right
everyone make their prediction votes for
a votes four votes for B okay this one's
pretty more pretty evenly split so I'll
show you the example so the the right
answer so it was a and then B it can be
tough to tell we actually ran a visual
Turing test like this where we gave
people 50 trials where they they made a
prediction and they got blocked feedback
so every 10 we told them how well they
were doing and on the y-axis here is the
identification level basically the
accuracy of the judges in a visual
attorney test mean yeah if they were 50%
they didn't have an ability to
discriminate so the red is the BPL model
and it's very close to two chance
performance but then if we lesion some
of the key ingredients that I was
telling you about where we we lesion
aspects of the learning to learn or
religion aspects of the compositionality
it becomes easier to tell that it's not
a human drawing the letter so I'll show
you what those look like
so here the beep the full model is the
left column the middle column is the is
a lesion model that doesn't have
compositionality so it tries to do
everything with one giant stroke and
some of them look okay but other
examples look kind of funny and the last
is if you lesion some of the learned
parameters from the data set and in this
case the model is way too stochastic and
again people can realize this is not how
a person would draw these things I'm
showing the importance of the principles
another task we looked at was one-shot
classification from a set of good
examples and this is the same demo that
we did earlier so we basically ran
people in the same task we show them one
image of a new character and we have
them try to pick out another image of
the same character and so Y axis here is
error rate in the classification task
and pink err people they're around 5%
error the red is the Bayesian program
learning model and it was similar error
to the people if you lesion the learning
to learn
in the compositionality the model gets
worse and we also tried various types of
deep learning models including a deep
convolutional neural net that was
trained on 30 alphabet other alphabets
and then tested on these or a deep
Siamese convolutional net which is a
little fancier version and a
hierarchical deep generative neural
network and in each case that it was you
know the error rate was was
significantly higher than then our model
and also worse than people so it's even
though these are very good models for
for recognition with a lot of data it's
a lot more difficult to perform well
when you just get a single data point
even if they're heavily pre trained so
this was with a set of held out alphabet
so it was trained on 30 and evaluated on
somewhere between 10 and 20 additional
alphabets yeah that's our cost a bunch
of different trials like that and I
think what's interesting about this is
people have been talking about the
importance the importance of generative
models and how good generative models
would be for if you could produce the
data you could classify the data well
but by and large discriminative models
have mostly won the the classification
game and and are have beaten generative
models in most types of classification
tasks and I think our contribution of
this work is to finally show that the
power generator models for
classification
especially in this small data setting
and if you get the representation of the
data right ok one more task and I'm just
gonna briefly flash up a couple movies
so here's a people drawing these 20
different letters I showed you a 20
different examples of this letter and
also the model drawing the the same
letters trying to predict how people
draw them so there's there some
similarities in terms of how the model
decides to draw letters and the way
people decide to draw letters and we did
an analysis of this but I'm not gonna go
through the details of that
okay so that's the first case study so
let's move on to recursive visual
concepts and this is joint work with
Steve pianted OSI at the University of
Rochester
so that the main idea there was concept
learning as a type of program induction
but if you think about the space of
possible programs the different types of
programs that one could write a motor
program is a relatively special case it
has unusually concrete and embodied
semantics so the the actual parts of the
programmer can be grounded out in terms
of motor actions and not all programs
are like that certainly only a small set
are so if the mind can genuinely write a
program to represent a new concept we
wanted to know what what are the limits
of this ability how how general is this
ability to to write a program to
represent data and in particular can it
learn more abstract types of programs
could learn classic programming
techniques like recursion could it learn
recursive programs and I think recursion
is interesting because it's not just an
abstract concept it's of course an
important part of language and thought
but also certain types of natural
concepts that that we reason about and
learn about in in the day to day
environment so here's a type of broccoli
or the feathers of a peacock or an ice
cave or a tree are all recursive
concepts that have this underlying
fractal structure to them and we were
curious to see whether we can teach
people very abstract versions of things
like this and again going back to this
idea of causality as an ingredient and
whether influences your perception if
you take the image at the top of the
screen and think about what is it more
similar to a or B well it's a plastic
tree that's absolutely but you knew it
was a plastic tree which is interesting
yeah so I I think I mean we got one
answer for B I bet there is awesome
people that wanted to pick a and the
reason why is because you have causal
knowledge here you know a might grow
into the thing at the top of the screen
whereas B is a similar color a similar
shape a similar size it's a type of
mistake that the deep convolutional
neural network might make but it shows
the importance of causality in terms of
your your intuitive similarity make
metric in terms of the basis of your
concepts entry but up what in the
computer community fellows great-looking
fractal Mountains and the first thing
boss says notches things to geologists
geologists look at geomorphology vastly
different than not you public do and
similarly you know you and I might see
think of that as a a Christmas tree
quote a Christmas tree but the reality
is a botanist say that's a particular
type of spruce or some other species or
something like that I certainly believe
that are you are you a botanist of any
button that no we have ok that's good to
know
well I apologize for forgetting you just
like that to professional audiences
makes a difference all right
okay so we wanted to explore the the
limits of this disability to induce a
program from data and we push one to
push the boundaries of the human
capacity in a few ways where we looked
at these abstract recursive visual
concepts we varied the number of
examples where we showed people just one
or a few examples from the concept and
we also tested a range of different ways
that people could generalize in terms of
classification and also generating new
examples of the underlying program so
here's the set up we told people that
there's a surface that was infected with
a new type of alien crystal and it was
growing for for some time so the before
image shows the surface and the after
image shows the crystal growing on the
surface so that's that's what this
crystal looks like and we asked them to
try to predict what the crystal will
look like if you let it grow an
additional for some additional period of
time so take a look here again I'll ask
for your your opinion do you think this
crystal is gonna grow into a it's gonna
grow into B or gonna grow into see the
votes ray votes for B okay yes yes lots
of computer scientists though it works
very well and we try another one so
faint same set up Crystal's been growing
for a while
that you have the before and the after
what is it gonna look like if the
continues to grow votes for a right also
very good good argument could be made
for C in the sense that your example
only shows one generation of triangles
springing up from the only line segment
that can spring up from but the next
generation triangles might be springing
up from duplicate line segments into the
same space and interacting in some way
that would not produce be you know the
lowest generation of triangles in be
very cleverly grew you know
cooperatively from both of the adjacent
segments where is something like see
might be an example of something where
they compete with each other another
argument is that see is fifteen steps
down and between the first two it's six
steps and we didn't see the the Eurasian
yes so I'll explain how they were
generated in a second and so there's a
there's a CO sort of coherent program
for for B and C maybe there is but but
but B definitely has sort of a nice
compression to it yeah good yeah so it
doesn't actually I'll explain exactly
how how how to grow these things um so
we wanted a language to to represent
these different types of simple
recursive visual concepts and the
language we chose or L systems and
turtle graphics so you might know L
systems Linda my earned systems from a
while back and and they're related to
context-free grammars internal graphics
are from the logo programming language
and still used I think to to teach intro
programming and the idea behind turtle
graphics is turtle is a little dot on
the screen and it has an orientation and
you can give turtle commands and you can
have turtle trace out a an interesting
contour like any of the ones on the
screen and I'll explain how how our
version of turtle works so turtle has
four different commands that you can
provide the legend is on the top right
of this slide you can tell turtle to
make a right turn which is a plus sign
in this symbolic language a left turn is
a minus sign F is the command that go
straight and G is another command that
means go straight but they're going to
have different rules of evolution and so
that's the legend for this simple turtle
language and the L system specifies on
the
in which turtle turn so it has a
consistent angle a start symbol which is
always F and then rewrite rules for the
strings so f becomes this this more
complicated string and G doubles
essentially and the difference between L
system and a context-free grammar is
that at every step of the at every
iteration you apply the rule in every
possible place rather than just apply at
once so in the first iteration F becomes
rewritten as that string on the right
hand side F minus G Plus F plus G minus
F and if you trace that out starting at
the left hand side of that canvas you
draw an upside down triangle and then if
you apply the rewrite rules again you
end up with this longer string which
looks like the image at the bottom so
that's the language we're going to use
to represent these different concepts
and we did a classification experiment
which was a lot like the demo we just
tried we use participants on Mechanical
Turk there they saw 24 different fractal
concepts they didn't get any feedback
they had 6 choices where the distractors
were made by taking the last step of the
examples and then using a different
rewrite rule rather than the correct one
and on there was two conditions there
was a latent condition where they just
saw the before and the after step of the
growth and there was a stepwise
condition where they saw a multi step of
the growth so there's more information
there and that's similar to a visual
recursion task that's been studied by
Martin and colleagues so there's a
psychological literature about this task
and whether people can do these type of
visual recursive inference
oh yes so so all the images are are
normalized too so they fit nicely into
the little window so when when you go to
additional level of recursion all this
the steps like essentially the figure
gets a lot bigger but then you you
normalize it to fit in the window it's a
good question so I'm just gonna flash up
the the 24 different stimuli and they
didn't get feedback after every judgment
and yeah there's a scaling issue that I
didn't see in your rule definition where
other generation align as a certain
length but the next generation down the
line is only half that yes how was that
conveyed and yes so they're they're
they're renormalize that are coming with
so they all fit nicely centered the span
the bottom of the campus but as it's
being drawn somehow the second
generation it knows not to draw a line
the same length yeah so it draws in some
abstract space that grows a lot bigger
in each iteration and then they're all
projected down into a normalized divided
by 2 if you wanted to get it back most
guys yeah so church ants in this task
would be around 16 percent correct
because it's one out of six people were
much better than that there are about
65% correct so they seemed to make
judgments classification judgments
consistent with the underlying program
and interestingly there is no difference
between the stepwise condition and the
latent condition or they just saw the
before and after we can make a Bayesian
program learning model of this where we
have a meta grammar M which is a
context-free grammar that generates L
systems so there's two layers of
grammars here we have a grammar which is
a little complicated I won't go into the
details of how that works but it
generates the rewrite rules of the L
system and so it forms a prior in a
Bayesian sense over the space of L
systems the L system can then you sample
how many iterations you want which is
the D a variable over there and that
determines what the image looks like and
we render that down into a binary image
and that's the generative process for
four images from this model and then we
can invert the model and talk about if
you just give the model the image reason
about what what are the possible
concepts these l-system concepts and
iterations given the image that you saw
so reason about the posterior
distribution on L and D given hi and we
use an MCMC algorithm to to search the
space
so there's there's an important note
here where the the model has some clear
advantages over people and that it has
exactly the right programming language
right and it knows about this special
class of growth like L systems but it
doesn't know about anything else and so
people can infer programs like these
it's because their programming language
or their language of thought is
sufficiently rich that includes things
like this
and many other things so I think it's
it's very interesting if people are able
to behave in a way that's even partially
as good as this this model is which has
a lot of advantages we also looked at
other measures of perceptual similarity
you can think of these as alternative
models we looked at modified house tour
F distance which is a classic distance
measure over binary images that
basically looks at the the pairwise
distance between pixels and two images
and and averages over all the different
pairwise distances and what's
interesting is if you try to make the
generalization to the next step it
always picks the image that has the
smallest perturbations to the original
so the one the top of middle is the
closest match to the one on the left and
it's quite far from the right answer
which is the middle at the bottom we
also like that a pre-training the deep
convolutional net so this used to be a
state of the art object recognition
system or was a few years ago and it
behaves quite similarly where it likes
small perturbations and it's quite far
in terms of the feature space from the
the underline the the real next
iteration of the program which is again
is shown at the bottom middle here so if
if we plot the models on this slide we
see that chance performance again around
16 percent correct the ComNet and the
house torque distance are around chance
definitely not not better than chance
the bayesian program induction model is
that 100% because it has you know
exactly the right language if you do
inference for a sufficiently long time
it will find the right answer and be
able to do the classification task
successfully so why why why aren't
people were at least generally
consistent although very
with this model now why aren't they
perfect like them all well my hypothesis
is that there's there's a failure of
search here and what you can do with the
with the model is it's a sampling based
inference procedure where you keep
drawing samples until it finds a region
of the posterior which fits the data
well but sometimes it never gets there
and you can actually fit the number of
samples that the model takes so that it
matches the human level of accuracy and
at least intuitively that's that's how I
feel when I look at these stimuli is
sometimes I can get the recursion I get
sort of a simple story but other times
you're just feel like you don't find it
and and you could model that potentially
by having limited amounts of sampling
and which will sometimes find the right
hypothesis and other times not if you do
this the model can do a decent job at
predicting what fractals people found
easier or harder to learn it gets around
the 0.57 correlation with the the
aggregate accuracy for the different
than 24 different concepts if you fit it
to the overall accuracy level and then
try to predict which concepts are easier
or harder to learn so there there is a
heuristic that is closely related to the
idea of being a recursive visual concept
or an l-system but isn't quite the same
thing which I called the look for a
smaller copy heuristic where if you take
iteration two and look for a smaller
copy of it in iteration three that will
actually do very well on on our task so
as closely related to getting the it
certainly means you've got some
recursive structure but it doesn't mean
you you got the else system in the full
extent so we did an another experiment
which was more unconstrained it was a
generation experiment and again there is
a step wise in a latent condition we
showed people in this case three
different steps of this of this concept
and then we asked them to try to
generate the next step or to generate
how it's going to continue to grow and
they were given an interface that looks
like this as a blown-up version of step
and this is how the interface worked it
was again on Mechanical Turk if you
hover over a segment you highlight it as
green and if you click on a green
segment it grows a little growth which
is the right kind of growth so we limit
them to two looking at gross that that
look like the actual underlying program
and then if you highlight it again it
shows up at red if you click it again it
goes away so you can sort of pick where
you want to try to grow the program from
the previous step we also gave people an
all button so if they click that all the
growths popped up and we gave people a
none button and if you click that they
all went away so you have this flexible
interactive display to try to grow what
you thought this this program would
evolve into again we did a similar
experiment there was a Layton condition
a stepwise condition they didn't forget
any feedback there were thirteen
different facto concepts not the full
set of 24 because some of them the
segments got very very very small and
you can't really see them or click them
so we didn't pick the 13 with the
largest segments and what we found was
there's a few different ways you can
measure accuracy each stimulus has a
bunch of different choices each click as
a choice in a sense so you could look at
for each individual decision was it
right or was it wrong each each click
and it was people were about 90 percent
correct in the stepwise condition for
each individual click and they were
about 70 percent correct in the latent
condition for each individual click we
can look at a couple different baselines
if you're just a random flip a coin a
fair coin responder that's the red line
here you get 50% correct the deep
convolutional net doesn't want to flip
any of the parts because the most
similar image is the original one and if
you just click none every time you get
around 57% accuracy so so those are the
baselines we also looked at whether
people generated exactly the right
example and interestingly in the
stepwise condition they did about 60% of
the time
in the latent condition they did around
27 23 percent of the time and we do you
have a bunch of different baselines here
as well so even the simplest stimulus
had 22 different possible places to
click so you're never if you're flipping
a coin you're never gonna get the right
answer just based on chance because
that's you know 1 over 2 to the 22 would
be your chances of randomly stumbling
upon even the right answer for even the
simplest stimulus so so the baseline is
0 in that sense but if you click the all
button every single time which is the
Purple Line you do about as well as the
Layton group did even though that's not
exactly what they did so the the Layton
group's not better than that baseline
necessarily but the step wise group this
is that's quite well at getting exactly
the right example in that in that space
so I'll show you just one or two
examples of what people individual
judgments look like so this is a step
wise condition they saw those steps this
is a particularly z example and here the
ground truth is on the left 14 people
everybody in this condition did exactly
the right thing which is good in the
latent condition 6 people did exactly
the right thing and the other people did
some interesting not so correct things
but it's it's still some of them were
interesting and reasonable other ones it
looks like they just click the all
button or something like that another
example so here's the step wise
condition for this fractal where 11
people got it exactly right and then 3
people did something different in this
in the stepwise condition but in the
latent condition only one person
happened to get it right and there was a
whole variety of strategies so to sort
of summarize I think there's there's
very a lot of variability in people's
judgments but I think by and large it
was consistent with this Bayesian
program learning model and certainly
better than these simple types of image
distance metrics also that the deep
convolutional network
and and so it's I think it's interesting
that people have an ability to learn
these simple recursive visual concepts
from from a small number of examples
okay so now I'm gonna get into the the
last case study and this is about asking
questions and this is joint work with
Anselm Roth and Todd grekes at NYU and
Ansel Meza is a fantastic graduate
student in the psych department and he's
been the lead on on this work yeah I
should also say this is this the the
least developed component so I'll tell
you about so the form of the model and
where we're going with it but it we're
still working on on the final results
and really sort of exploring the full
potential of what we think this model
could you okay so I started with this
slide earlier about human level active
learning and the type of rich questions
maybe a child will ask compared to the
simple stereotyped questions that are
they're common in active learning and we
want up to think about what types of
models would be capable of doing the
same thing asking asking rich types of
questions the main idea here is that we
can model a question as as a simple
program where if you run the program on
the world stage it will return an answer
and then thinking of a question is the
process of synthesizing an informative
program that will give you an answer if
it was run on the world that helps you
learn what you wanted to learn and we
wanted a testbed for studying this type
of question asking and so we wanted a
task that allowed people to ask rich
questions any question they wanted but
we wanted it to be again simple enough
that it was amenable to formal in
particular ideal Bayesian modeling so we
could figure out exactly how good the
questions are that they asked so we
picked the game of Battleship which as
you can see on the box is America's
all-time favorite game
so if you want a refresher on on
battleship this is our variant the
battleship where we there are these
three ships the blue the purple in the
red and they have different sizes
they're somewhere between two and four
tiles long and they're hidden somewhere
in this configuration and there's
there's 1.6 million possible
configurations for where the ships could
be and as the learner if you're playing
the game of battleship again someone
else you don't know where the ships are
at all at the beginning and you you
click on the grid squares and then it
colors in the tiles and this starts to
give you information about where the
ships might be so the the dark grey
tiles here are this is where you click
somewhere and you didn't get any evident
there was no ship there you're just
hitting water so in regular battleship
you sample all the way through and then
you make a guess about where the ships
are but in our version a battleship you
had a special opportunity to ask any
question you wanted about the game board
part of the way through the game so on
Mechanical Turk we gave people a text
box that said what do you want to ask
about the board you can ask anything and
they typed out a question in natural
language you might ask is the red ship
horizontal or not and there were just a
couple constraints that the questions
had to be answerable in a single word so
you couldn't be like tell me where all
the ships are because there's no
one-word answer that will reveal that
and also we to ask them not to try to
combine many questions together yeah
I'll I'll get to that question later so
so here's here's the results for this
particular game board so this is what a
bunch of different people in Mechanical
Turk looked at and here are the
questions that came up with and this was
a lot of fun because we thought a lot
about questions and people surprised us
and came up with better questions that
any any of us working on this project
came up with ourselves in particular a
few people like to ask what is the
location of the top left part of the
purple ship
that's a really good question for this
board because it gives you a purple tile
and when you get that tile it tells you
something about the geometry of the
whole ship so it's a really good
informative question other things people
asked were honest the location of one
purple tile as the blue ship horizontal
as the red ship two tiles long we just
had a very long list of a bunch of
interesting things that that people
asked and they saw 18 different
configurations like this and then we
went through a sort of a painstaking
process of coding the semantics of every
question so there's a whole bunch of
different ways that you could ask the
question how big is the blue ship right
you could ask how many square as long as
the blue ship how long is the blue ship
how many tiles is the blue ship there's
a bunch of different ways to ask it in
natural language at all boiled down to
just asking about the size of a blue
ship so they were all the questions all
I think 700 something questions were
coded into these functions that were on
that encoded the semantics and then we
have the list of all of unique questions
that people have staring battleship and
I know you can't see that at all so I'll
show you a few examples some of the
questions were like the location
questions very standard questions in
battleship these are people that weren't
creative at all they just clicked
basically asked about particular grid
squares where they the n is how many
people asked the question so they'd
asked like what is the color at some
particular tile that's that's not a very
creative question but it was asked 24
different times there is questions about
different regions of the board here are
the questions about the size of ships so
a lot of people asked how many tiles is
the red ship for instance or that is the
red ship three tiles long question
questions about size they're also these
demonstration queries which are
especially informative asking about what
is the location in one purple tile what
is the location shown on the top left
part of the purple ship and so on so we
did a second experiment where we showed
people different people the same
scenarios and gave them a list of six
questions that were generated by other
people and we wanted to see
they had a sense of what's a good
question or not in battleship so we
asked them to sort them from their
favorite question to the least favorite
question and they got the answer to
their top trading question and then they
had to try to guess where the ships were
right after they got the answer and they
their bonus was dependent on how well
they guess where the ships were so they
were motivated to do well and we also
needed a measure of how do you know what
question is good or not so we you can
write down a busy and ideal observer
model for battleship where each here is
a hypothesis about the gameboard
configuration where the ships are X is a
candidate question that you might ask
and D represents a possible answer to
that question so you can use Bayes rule
the reason about the probability of our
particular hypothesis given that you got
an answer D to question X and basically
it's just eliminating all of the
configurations that are inconsistent
with the answer to your question so you
can do this so overall 1.6 million
hypotheses if you're a Bayesian reasoner
and also compute an expected information
gain of a question so the expected
information gain of a question X is your
expected reduction in entropy from your
prior to your posterior over the
different possible answers to your
question so it's summing over all
answered possible answers D to your
question of the expected information
gain of getting that particular answer
to your question and basically it just
boils down to good questions rule out a
lot of hypotheses and that's this
normative metric of of how good a
question is so if you look at people's
rankings of the questions and look at
the expected information gain measure
from the ideal reasoner on the x axis is
the preference of the ideal reasoner for
the six different questions each each
scatterplot here is a different game
board configuration and the y axis is
the average rank score of people where 5
Mets everybody ranked it as the best
question and one means everyone ranked
it as the worst question and you can
get an average of between that and
there's a nice relationship and in most
configurations between the ideal the
ideal observer models expected
information gain and people's
preferences and the average correlation
was about point eight two so people seem
to know when when there was a very good
question and they picked it and I think
there's there's something right about
this where sometimes it can be hard to
generate a really good question but if
you know you're the audience of a talk
and you hear a really good question you
often feel like oh that's a great
question even if you didn't necessarily
think of it yourself and what what this
is if battleships anything like real
life in that sense people see at least
had a very keen understanding of when a
good question was asked in battleship so
so um what I think the most exciting
part about this domain and what this
project is trying to do is ask can we
build machines that ask richer more
human-like types of questions during
learning and there's a lot of benefits
from this if machines could ask better
questions they could learn from less
data and also you could have a more
natural type of interaction between
humans and machines so the main idea is
that we can model questions as programs
programs that when you run them on the
world state or the game board in this
case they return an answer and there are
some primitive programs programs that
are essentially just handed to the just
it that come from the instructions of
the game they're they're very simple
like a program that asks for the size of
the blue ship so these are written in in
Lisp notation so size is the function
name and blue is the argument and so
that's a program that asks for the size
of the blue ship you also have a
primitive program that asks for the
color at a particular tile or the
orientation of the blue ship and what's
very nice is that these programs are
compositional and you can exploit
compositionality to get richer types of
programs and people actually ask those
questions so a lot of people asked what
is the total size of all the ships if
you added them together and you can get
that of course by taking the the basic
program
that asks for the size of each ship and
adding them all together so you can use
the the addition operator as a means of
compositionality to to make the question
or at least represent its semantics um
you could also ask are the blue ship in
the red ship parallel and this is just
asking whether their orientation
functions return the same answer
so again compositionality just like some
of the previous models gives you this
productive expressive power to
synthesize richer questions from from
simpler ones and helps to represent some
of the things that people ask in the
game there's also I think learning to
learn going on where people didn't think
of parallel for the first time when they
were asking that question they of course
we're transferring this existing concept
from general world experience to this
particular game so so there's definitely
a component of previous learning
influencing how you ask questions
and just to to hammer home this point a
little bit more you can ask a lot of
different variants of the same question
like how many ships are three tiles long
or any ships three towels long are all
the ships three tiles long and for this
you can take the same basic program
which Maps a function that checks
whether each ship is size three and by
changing the outside operators by either
adding up all the results or checking if
the sum is greater than zero or checking
if the sum is equal to three you can
represent all these variants of the same
question by just changing the the outer
operators of an inner function so there
compositionality buys you a lot so we
actually wrote a simple program for
every question in the data set that
people asked and then we wrote a
context-free grammar that generates
every single question that people asked
and many other questions so every
question that people asked is
grammatical as well as many other
possible types of questions and of
course that's very hard to parse but I
can give you a little intuition about
how it works so there's there's
non-terminal symbols in and the base
symbol is an answer right so every
program returns an answer and this
represents the basically the return type
of the program an answer could be a
boolean or a number or color an
orientation or a location so you could
transform the a symbol into any of those
and then let's say you pick a boolean
well maybe um it's the result of an
equality operator between two colors so
you might pick equal CC and then you
might figure out functions that return a
type of color and then you can represent
things like is there a red tile at eight
one and that's how you generate it was
sort of a context free way from a set of
rules and this generates everything
people asked and many other things and
you you keep sampling until you ground
out all the non terminals with with
actual pieces of the program so this
this is about aware where we are in
terms of how this how we've implemented
this this algorithm and we've already
learned a lot of interesting things so
we first
just tried to say okay once what's the
best question you could possibly ask if
you're gonna optimize expected
information gain what's the best
question possible and ran you know
genetic algorithms to search for the
best question and what came out - to our
surprise was interesting so and you
imagine you someone might ask what's the
size of the red chip because they want
to know the size of the red chip but the
model is greedy and it wants to know the
size of the red chip but it also wants
to know the size of the blue ship and
the size of the purple chip right so it
constructed basically these complicated
polynomial expressions where it would
say give me a hundred times the size of
the purple ship plus ten times the size
of blue ship plus size of the red ship
and then it wouldn't stop there would
ask about every other thing it could add
string together this like totally
unintuitive wall at polynomial thing
because they didn't actually use base 10
it would use some arbitrary coding
scheme yeah and then yes that I guess
would be a valid question I'm very
thankful know what nobody chose that's
that because I'm not sure what we would
have bet but yes
fortunately the text box so so that's
what the model does it's just looking
for all optimal questions and so that's
not what people did for a lot of reasons
maybe the length and the complexity of
that question is too much maybe they're
being nice to the answerer
and they said I don't want to do that to
anybody
maybe I'll try to answer this question
so we're trying to fit a model to sample
questions but human-like questions it's
actually put a probability distribution
on this very complicated space of
programs and um and what what were you
using log linear models basically so the
probability of sampling a question is
proportional to this feature vector x
whether or not each question has this
feature and the features are things like
length and whether it uses various
grammatical operators and so on it
there's a lot of really interesting
questions into space like really truly
novel
things like rather than just the top
left of the purple ship you can ask in
the grammar what's the top left tile of
any ship so if you take all the top left
queries from all the different ship
colors and then wrap that in a top left
then you can get an even better question
that nobody asked so we're really
excited about seeing what the model
comes up with in terms of it sort of
best team and like questions and try to
use it to predict what people would ask
on a new configuration and eventually
try to develop this technique so that
you can apply it to two different types
of games on beyond beyond this setting
okay so on the title of the talk was
concepts and questions as programs and I
talked about these three different
domains and how we represented them in
in in programs and other domains that I
think have a structure a lot like this
are are of course Henry and characters
but other causal compositional embodied
concepts that that are often symbolic
like learning a new gesture or learning
a new dance move or learning a new
spoken word like a unfamiliar name and
all these cases if you see a new gesture
like you know a high-five or a secret
handshake if you've never seen it before
you could probably recognize it again
and you could even produce it yourself
and part of that I think is because you
have this rich causal knowledge this
rich causal model of how that action
could have been produced you could
produce it yourself it's also
compositional there's some basic
primitives behind it I think all these
domains have have some aspect of that in
common and so this this approaches might
be especially fruitful for for domains
like that there are also lots of domains
where I think causality this which was
the second principle is is very
important for how we learn and use
concepts so what makes those two
fractals in the same concept what makes
those two images of trees part of the
same concept or just the way you reason
about objects in the real world where
you walk into cave and you think about
how it was formed or whether it's
dangerous to be in that cave or if you
think about a tree and
you don't just not just recognize that
it's a tree or what species is it but
you think about what way is that tree
gonna grow is it too close to my house
if you think about all the different
types of judgments that that you can
make the different ways you use these
concepts I think you you tap into the
the causal knowledge in addition to just
a future based representation of them
and and finally for this sort of active
learning as synthesizing programs idea
you can use programs to represent the
the compositional structure of the
semantics of questions and hopefully
develop algorithms that can ask richer
and more interesting types of questions
for different types of learning
scenarios and games so to conclude for
the the two parts on concepts we asked
this question how do people learn rich
concepts from very small amounts of data
and I think this Bayesian program
learning approach helps to answer this
question for a range of simple visual
concepts we've talked about characters
and also the recursive visual concepts
and the model embodies three different
principles compositionality causality
and learning to learn which were
important for the model to be able to
successfully learn programs from small
amounts of data and for the part about
questions how do people synthesize novel
interesting rich questions when faced
with uncertainty I think this idea that
you can represent a question as a
program is a powerful one and it again
uses the principles of compositionality
and learning to learn to get there so
that the last piece is a new project but
I think it's it's exciting and I hope
these ideas will be useful for
developing or human-like learning
algorithms thank you
questions you've had a comparison
between and your headlight your
handwritten system is in doing
recognition and so on and I'm curious so
you showed the the the Bayesian
programming learning was better than
convolutional neural networks and you
cited the benefit of hat being able to
train on less data but I'm curious
because really there's two disadvantages
the neural network is that the first is
that it has less data and the second is
that it's sort of like topology set up
such that it can only learn this very
general framework it does not guarantee
necessary to learn the concepts so I'm
curious if like given enough time it
would have eventually learned the
concepts or food was actually set up
such that it could never understand the
concepts in the same way that you sort
of hard-coded them in the system that
like you know you would have characters
in this way or that do any intuition
behind that answer because I'm here as
to what extent you can take these
lessons and incorporate them into these
deep learning demands
yeah thanks that's that's a great
question and I I think it's still an
open one to some extent that we don't
know if given enough data if it'll
eventually learn you know the the same
representation that we have in our model
or whether it will take you know an
infinite amount of data to get there and
certainly if you train it on the 30
background alphabets in and our data set
it doesn't get far enough to to that
type of to the accuracy that our model
has but you can make a very good
classifier with deep neural network from
tens twenties maybe a hundred examples
of of each letter so if your ultimate
goals classification then you can do
very well with with that type of
technique but it doesn't necessarily
learn the same type of representation
and it if it particularly if it's a
convolution that it doesn't generalize
in any other of the other ways that we
looked at here so there's also a lot of
other people working on building models
of this data set and using some more
generative type of neural networks
things like variational auto-encoders to
try to build generative models of of
letters and that can not only do
education but can produce new new
examples and the samples look pretty
good they capture some aspects of what
our model can do but there they also
generalize in ways that our model does
not in people clearly do not and
sometimes it just produces totally the
wrong character so I think it's they
still they're getting closer they have a
ways to go before we know if you can
capture this type of generative process
in a neural network and part of the
reason why it's so difficult I think is
because everyone's training the model on
just the images and our model of course
they're trained on the images and also
the the motor representation and it's
hard to fit that type of representation
to train on that directly in a neural
network but I think it would have a huge
payoff in terms of getting insight into
the rights of causal process the right
type of prior and if you were able to
encode that you might be able to
generalize and in a way like our model
does so I think it's certainly possible
and I think you train on the right type
of data and incorporated the principles
in the right way you certainly might be
able to do it but we haven't quite got
there yet look wasn't all that's great
case study some kind of symbolic
reasoning that you can use to get to the
right answer but think about scenarios
where we ourselves understand how the
brain works for instance how do we
generate natural images not around there
is not enough discrete choices that you
can make to get
I got a very good question and certainly
we certain types of natural images I
think have a causal structure that's a
lot like um what the Bayesian program
learning approach can represent and like
those those are things like the broccoli
and the ice cave that have a sort of a
clear causal story behind it of course
that's not every type of natural concept
there's a lot where you you might look
at an object and there isn't a clear
causal story behind it you may not know
about what the right parts are in the
same way so for for those cases I I
think there could be value in both
approaches or sort of a synthesis of
both approaches where there's there's
definitely discrete structure and in
lots of different types of objects that
you may not have the same so
domain-specific generative knowledge
about like you know chairs or or animals
or cars where there's clear part
structure that could easily be encoded
and explicitly in the model but you may
not know how to relate that deeper part
structure the deeper causal structures
to the actual image so I think there
might be a role to play for sort of
feature-based deep learning style so a
representation learning to figure out
how to connect up that latent structure
that you know that is there for sure
with the actual image and you might be
able to to get both approaches to work
together in a way that would highlight
both of those strains so that's I we
don't have systems that really work like
that yet but I think that would be a
really exciting direction to go I should
also say something about scenes scenes
in general are a case where I think
having a richer causal model is
especially important and this is beyond
a single objects but you look at a scene
like an audience set at a presentation
and you see many objects together
interacting right there's a bunch of
seats and people sitting in the seats
and you can tell why that scene is the
way it is or if deep deep networks or
particularly the captioned generating
systems that try to understand the scene
as a whole rather than particular
objects have special trouble putting the
objects together in a coherent story and
if they they see a scene that doesn't
look like the type of training data that
they have
they often generate captions that don't
make a lot of sense if you run a deep
caption generation system lawn like news
images so you sort of obscure events and
the model was trained on you know
vacation photos it produces four really
terrible captions for for these unusual
scenarios for things that happen the
news so there I think there really is a
need to have rich causal structure to
piece together the data that you see and
there's a special benefit for having
representations that that might look
something like this
the way we're evaluating it is - it's a
full probabilistic model so we can
actually evaluate it on a new battleship
board that it was never trained on and
look at the set of questions that people
ask and ask what's the likelihood of
those questions under the model and see
if the model can predict people's
questions with a high probability as
opposed to a simpler model or our model
that takes a different different type of
approach so we can actually quantitative
we have some quantitative measure of
what it means to be human like question
Kenny can you actually predict people's
questions in a novel scenario so that's
one of the metrics that we're going to
use so that's the other exciting thing
you can do with the model you can then
sample questions that nobody thought to
ask so what what is it think the most
probable things are that nobody asked
and we don't we haven't quite gone that
far but I'm very curious to see what
what is going to do
yes this might not be a fair question
because it's sort of philosophical and
sort of skeptical oh great I've seen a
lot of talks on deep network
problem-solving and there seems to be a
sort of bias that the problems being
solved our problems that the researchers
are choosing to solve because they know
a priori that this problem can be solved
by the network I'm using it may not be
the real problem autonomous vehicles are
big in the news machine vision
navigation deep networks they had
trained their mobile eye with 1,400
different models of cars that it
shouldn't hit and for each car what it
looked like from the front and the back
and sides and as long as you're driving
on a surface that had nothing with these
models you wouldn't run into any of them
and then the Tesla ran underneath the
truck and had the top of the car shaved
off in Florida and I heard an expert say
clearly Tesla was negligent because they
didn't train it how to recognize trucks
parked sideways across the highway that
it shouldn't drive under but the next
training set will fairly overlook or
will clearly include that is something
they'll teach it not to hit that can't
be the way life forms work the bird
doesn't keeps flying into vehicles until
learns which vehicles not flying yeah is
there some black of reality you were
practicality or asking the wrong
questions that maybe infecting the deer
bowl disappointment Oh first that's
that's a very deep good philosophical
question and I I don't know how well
like how long it's gonna take to get
those systems to the level of accuracy
that we're really happy with in terms of
having enough training data and and be
able to drive it in a way that that
we're all
happy with I am pretty certain that they
don't drive in a human-like way
currently and I think some of the ways
that people drive in and analyze the
scene are would be really useful if we
had those in and those systems right and
so it's against this causal principle in
terms of looking at the scene and
understanding why is it there and what's
going on and if you see a someone
running into the street like a car is
very good at detecting a pedestrian
it'll stop and say potential pedestrian
but it doesn't go the step further to
try to say why is the person running
through the street are they not looking
are they chasing a ball and those those
types of inferences figuring out like
what the person you know belief is what
what they're trying to do whether
they're paying attention or not or very
automatic and very important part of our
perception and I I think they can be
very important for for making
predictions and and understanding what
to do in a scenario like that and so I
think looking to people there again
could be helpful and and and sort of
making systems that can can do well in
those edge cases that that the training
data may may not represent well this is
sort of the shame but people think about
people as having brains that are a
pattern recognition analog thing half
and another half that's analytical you
know you could look at a machine vision
problem as what are the characteristics
of everything you don't want to run in
queue and you might get there eventually
by feeding it hundreds of thousands of
things you don't want to run into until
you've exhausted them all or you might
think in terms of how does any solid
object cast an image on the retina and
what are the qualities of getting closer
to a solid object no matter what color
it is or anything else
now what's inherent in things that
shouldn't be there and
my the real solution for such things
attack each problem from both directions
strictly analytical and strictly pattern
recognition and try to come to a
synthesis which supposedly is no bridge
that sounds like a great idea yeah I
think that the intuitive understanding
of the physics of a scene is again very
important and very cognitively natural
and being able to combine that with the
data-driven and pattern recognition
approach would be like a very good idea
so it seems like most most of the work
is very heavily on the pattern
recognition side but that seems like a
great great idea well let's look the
video guy run and then we can then we
can find out what's really true let's
see the better thank you